this kid jumped off
oh my god
oh bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
apparently this kid was on a cruise ship
some folks dared him to jump off he did
and it's been three days they haven't
found his body and they haven't found
him alive Coast Guard called off the
search because they assumed he's done
for
there was a buoy that was thrown out to
give him some support he swam away from
it some people suspect because he saw a
predator in the water and so he panicked
and swam away from it so
if you're unaware
um the water's in the area which I
believe was the Caribbeans were very
sharp infested and this was for his
graduation his parents sent him on a
cruise right after he graduated
so there's the whole gist of the story
thoughts
ah
Oh my days
you're a parent
and then the first few years of having a
kid
your job is to keep that
that thing alive
and making sure everything is okay
and being stressed and going to the
doctors
and you make sure everything is okay and
it's all right you have sleepless nights
and that kid that kid kids they should
really try to do dumb [__] but not
because they know just because they
actually don't they're store in their
area and your job as a parent
is for your kids not to yourself
no don't cross the street we're looking
both ways no don't do this we're doing
that don't put that in your mouth you're
gonna choke don't do this don't do that
don't do that
and then it's a struggle cause you're
trying to have your kids grow and go to
school and that
have all the trials and tribulation that
goes with going to school
and he finally goes it's cool
and then you try to teach them right
and he finally graduate and then this
I feel for the parents goddamn
that's crazy
just for a dare
oh wow listen 18 year olds already have
a minus one to wisdom put some alcohol
in them they get a minus two and my man
that evening when he was there too
and they said jump off the boat he
rolled in that one and that was a
critical failure
big mistaking judgment
um you don't even want to say something
crazy like natural selection like some
people I guess we're just going straight
to that
listen young people do dumb things
some of us get to survive it some of us
don't
most of us do
we've also done some really stupid that
if you guys think back I like I could
have lost my life when I was crossing
the street this way or when I drank this
much or I took these drugs not looking
at what it was like we've all done
something that was incredibly dumb
this one's pretty intense that's intense
I don't care what nobody says I don't
care what the [__] age I am I ain't
jumping no [__] goddamn water no
Caribbeans
number two I ain't jumping no goddamn
Caribbean Waters at night not gonna
happen and you know it's wild you know
is that you're gonna get back on the
boat how are you gonna get back on the
boat how you gonna get back on the boat
maybe I grew up on Joss I watched Samuel
Jackson get eaten
that's not real but it's real to meaning
I'll say this you know what it is about
black people okay listen the way Samuel
died this is just immigrants in general
this is what I believe about immigrants
and this is why most immigrants are
looking at us like white people stuff
that's why I say this because here's the
thing immigrants generally like don't
believe in ghosts no but if you tell us
a house is haunted we're not going in so
we're not going even though we don't
believe in it we're just like it don't
matter I'm not gonna be the one to find
out if it's real or not you got
you gotta find out that's it [__] around
I see this house it's like come on bro I
feel for so I remember when I was like
on a trip in Hawaii like 2015. and we we
took a trip on a boat right we had a
kayak with my girl and then we had a guy
right so we were uh uh in this seat all
right uh we were paddling and stuff like
that and then someone from our group
asked the guide uh excuse me
how do we know if there's sharks in the
water and the guide went like this he
was a dude from south of the states and
then it wrote me an ex rugby player and
he moved to Hawaii and this dude look at
that lady is like well it's very same
for my girl you're gonna take your
finger like this you're gonna dip it in
the water you're gonna take it out
you're gonna put it in your mouth
is it salty Yep they're sharks all right
so moving on over there
wait on he went off there's water and
salt sharks don't know where the [__] is
uh uh yeah yeah no they don't know they
don't know where the borders are oh no
I'm not I'm not jumping in that water
now
um you do kayaking it and I see kayaks
slip all the time
now you you risking it too yeah yeah you
just like Cameron but you're a grown man
you even dumber yeah
but I had my life vest on and I was
sitting in that [__] right here I'll be
right here sir yes yes right I'ma stay
my Imma Stay my ass right here in that
cat anyways I feel for the parents for
real for real I sure that is so
devastating for the parents I can't even
imagine how much it is uh how bad it
should be feeling oh my God over that
but the reason why we cover this story
is is so that you guys that are watching
don't think about doing this dumb [__]
I'm serious
this is not a story I would like to
cover normally but I've covered this
some of y'all gotta stop [__] around
so apparently a lot of uh Crews on
cruise ships were saying that this is
very common behavior that people do dumb
stuff where they jump off and they go
missing or that people just risk it and
don't listen to any of the security
measures put in place because they think
it's just a party it's like yes you are
having a party you're having a good time
all the food's taken care of but there
are rules in place and sometimes people
think them rules are dumb and just want
to do whatever they want because they're
on vacation I see it all the time people
jumping over the zoo fans doing this
because they just travel to another city
[__] around a lot of crew people who
work on cruise ships are just like yep
done seen it it's tragic but
should have listened to them rules and
I'm not even mad at them you know you
guys want to have a happy ending but at
the end of the day there's consequences
in life so yeah what's the dumbest thing
you ever did when you risked your life
what is the dumbest thing I was probably
include speed yeah it's just like moving
really fast
might be skydiving
like multiple times
and then after that I said okay I think
I'm done for this for the rest of my
life I had like a whole like phase when
I was like 19 or 20 where I was just
doing everything that scared the [__]
out of me okay this car diving oh this
guy I do that because I'm terrified
Heights I think it's pretty fun
to me personally I could live with every
like I don't need to do that [__] again
but um how many times you do it three
times why three it's like one was not
enough I paid for seven technically you
paid for seven and then they want to
keep going oh here I'm scared of heights
I told myself
I I used to have this corny saying where
it's like if you're afraid of something
just run at it like headed first so I
remember I started off first by like
sitting on the edge of a building put my
feet dangling over which was
you know I have my like even just
thinking about it makes me anxious and
then I did the sky about anything I was
gonna do that I did a bunch of roller
coasters and I'm like okay I'm still
terrified
I know I can do it if I need to I'm
sorry sir
um
skydiving and having your feet dangling
in roller coasters are really not the
same thing roller coasters is one thing
skydiving it's the number some other
[__] having your feet then go off a
building
yeah like you just sit on the edge I
know what you mean yeah he was just
thinking about the site
I swear to God
you say that but when you're terrified
it all feels like the same [__]
Terror can only go so high
sure yeah at any rate that's all for
today anything else you want to say
[Laughter]